vergiss gekauften Humus wir machen Humus
selbst der cremiger fluffiger und
leckerer ist mmh los geht's du musst nur
bereit sein dein Mixer sauber zu machen
in den gebe ich eine Dose Kichererbsen
einfach wie sie rauskommen ohne Wasser
klar aber wir schälen die nicht wir
machen gar nichts kann man alles machen
wir wollen eine Alternative zum
gekauften dazu den Saft einer Zitrone
Knoblauch Mixer an wenn das vorgemixt
ist geben wir vier Esslöffel dahin dazu
etwas Olivenöl noch dazu eine Prise Salz
Deckel drauf und zum Abschluss eiswürfe
rein das ist ein Trick um die Konsistenz
zu verbessern
falls die Klinge von eurem Mixer nicht
greifen ein bisschen Öl oder Wasser
hinzu
konsistenzcheck wow so soll Humus
Aussehen Laden unseren Teller voll
streichen das Ganze aus boah junge ein
bisschen zu Markt drüber etwas
Kreuzkümmel drüber fertig ist unser